il n'y a pas eu de combat puisque une
fois de plus été victime de son de son
cynisme de son agressivité de son
sarcasme
alors oui mais comme il n'est pas là
c'est possible on peut sortir aussi si
vous voulez faire la maligne et avec moi
on peut y aller dit mois et est toujours
en travaux - c'est comme paris
bétonner elle aime bien vous avez mis un
petit samedi un petit zodiac l'a fait
une petite injection à temps d'arrêter
d'injecter parce que vous à l'explosif
non moi je le dis je l'assumé
ça nous a mis un stylet pour la langue
place humaine tu avais parlé au foie a
annoncé horrible accueillant balmont
c'est sexy elle est sublime avait fullum
bonsoir jour il fallait pas de vous en
fait d'être animée
[Applaudissements]
deux jours pour mes vieux moi ce matin
aux urnes on en reparlera avec
l'émission d'hier et vos petites
lunettes là on voit même pas voter
[Applaudissements]
ça ça va faire un carton alors le moi
même c'est que c'est à nonac après la
naissance et g par jour ça va changer
pour voitures alors qu'est-ce que vous
avez de matadi qu'est-ce qui m'a dit
quoi mais je sais pas vous êtes allé
voir un chirurgien pour vos vieux ça
maintenant je n'ai pas pu y aller non
mais non parce que vous savez hier j'ai
eu il ya eu un combat un peu mal tout ça
vous dirait tôt enfin disons pourquoi
ouailles n'ont pas du tout paquito
réparatrice
non ce qui est dommage c'est que avec la
chambre respective il faut aimer pour le
cerveau si vous allumez trouver l'amour
vous êtes beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
c'est très ouvert mais la habra problème
de gabarit quand même
[Rires]
[Musique]